Here is a plot showing infection rate of the Code One Version Two Worm which
ultimately infected 350,000 vulnerable hosts. Note the shape
of this curve. The worm is effectively dormant
or spreading extremely slowly for quite a
period of time. And then there's a inflection
point at which point the infection rate becomes
exponential At some point then, infections slow and
the infection rate ultimate plateaus, presumably after
all of the infected hosts have been found.
We can actually model the spread of these
worms using the random constant spread model. If
Kis the initial compromised rate, N is the
number of vulnerable hosts, and a is the
fraction of hosts already compromised, we can now
express the number of hosts infected at a
particular time increment in terms of the machines already
infected, and the rate at which uninfected machines become compromised. So
if Nda. Is the number of newly infected machines
in DT, we can express that in terms of the number of machines
already infected. Which is, N times a. So these are the
host already capable of doing more scanning. And now K times 1 minus a
is the rate at which uninfected machines
become compromised, in a particular time interval
dt. If we solve for a the fraction of hosts compromised, which is effectively
the y-axis of this graph and we get the following. You get an exponential curve
that is exponential where the growth rate depends
only on K, or the initial compromise rate.
This is very interesting because it tells us
that if we want to design a very fast
spreading worm, then we should design a worm
such that the initial compromise rate is as high
as possible. So how do we increase K.
Or how do we increase that initial compromise rate?